everyone loves a good villain and
disney's baddies are among the most
beloved and feared in all of cinema
but while their hideous scales and evil
plans are more than enough to scare the
kids
there are a few aspects to these
villains that only adults will pick up
on
it's hard to forget ursula the big bad
of 1989's the little mermaid
with her particularly deceitful scheme
her eel henchmen
and her instantly iconic music number
poor unfortunate souls
ursula has easily become one of the most
distinct members of the disney villain
canon
but something else sets ursula apart
from her fellow disney baddies
and that's her real life inspiration of
all people
ursula had her design based on the
famous drag queen and actor
divine so just how did the star of
raunchy john waters movies like pink
flamingos and multiple maniacs
come to inspire the villain of a g-rated
disney musical
well animator rob minkoff drew up a
design of ursula
that ended up bearing a strong
resemblance to divine
little mermaid composer howard ashman a
major fan of both john waters and divine
strongly endorsed the design choice
disney's other animators took further
visual influence from divine by giving
ursula a hairstyle
similar to the one done by the drag
queen in pink flamingos
the connection between the two only grew
as ashman committed to channeling
divine's uber-confident persona
into ursula's performance during poor
unfortunate souls
the hunchback of notre dame broke down
many barriers in the world
of disney animation for one thing this
1996 adaptation of victor hugo's novel
explicitly tackled the subject of
religion
which no other film in the studio's
canon has done
for another it gave a truly adult
motivation to its antagonist
claude frollo as in hugo's original
novel
frollo is a studious justice minister
who frowns upon anything
sexual in nature however the character
of esmeralda
a person frollo publicly refers to as
disgusting filth
stirs up feelings of passion inside
frollo's heart
his internal conflict over these
forbidden emotions becomes so great
that his villain musical number hellfire
is fixated on him begging for
forgiveness from god for feeling such
intense lust
where other disney villains are
motivated by greed or revenge
frollo's crisis is dictated entirely by
his sexuality
this is unexpectedly bold storytelling
territory from disney
a studio that spent the 1990s releasing
more explicit kitty fare
like this
earthwormy goodness indeed upon its
initial release
the los angeles times reported letters
from parents
questioning the movie's darker material
including frollo's internal conflict
were too adult for a kid's movie
nonetheless by daring to give its
villains such a complex and mature
motivation
the hunchback of notre dame was able to
solidify itself as one of the more
unique
and underrated disney animations
over the years everyone from claude
reigns to oscar isaac
has portrayed robin hood's greedy
nemesis prince john
so when it was time for disney to take
on the story of robin hood
it was inevitable that the filmmakers
were going to create their own unique
version of the character
and in disney's 1973 animated classic
john is portrayed as a cowardly thumb
sucking lion
voiced by two-time academy award winner
peter yustanov
disney's prince john quickly became one
of the most iconic versions of the
character
and for obvious reasons one of the
silliest and most cartoonish too
so much so in fact that it can be easy
to forget that prince john was
in fact a real historical figure long
before the release of disney's film
king john ruled over england for 17
years
between 1199 and 1216.
sadly there's little historical evidence
connecting jon and the semi-mythical
figure of robin hood in the real world
however the frequently antagonistic
depiction of jon in pop culture
stems from how he has been commonly
regarded as one of england's worst kings
as far as kings go jon didn't have a lot
going for him
he lost critical lands in france sent
england into financial ruin
and most famously of all was forced to
sign the magna carta
after facing a revolt from his own
barons john
quickly cultivated a toxic reputation
amongst contemporaries
one that survives to this day in stories
like robin hood
so while children will appreciate
disney's take on prince john as a
particularly silly entry into the
pantheon of disney villains
the grown-ups will be more than aware of
the real man
who presented an equally real danger to
his own people
unlike most animated disney movies
pocahontas
is actually based on a true story
however its deviations from reality have
inspired a decent amount of criticism
over the years
including the lack of evidence for there
having been a romantic relationship
between john smith
and pocahontas and one of the more
significant changes in the movie's plot
can be found in the fate of its villain
john ratcliffe in disney's pocahontas
ratcliffe is depicted as a gold hungry
captain who puts his own selfish
interests above
all else including the safety of the
indigenous americans
and with his love of money power and
flamboyant fashion sense
radcliffe fits nicely alongside his
fellow disney villains
unlike most disney villains however
ratcliffe is based on an actual person
the real ratcliffe was an early settler
to america who eventually became the
second president of the jamestown colony
whereas pocahontas depicts ratcliffe
being tied up and taken back to
england to pay for his crimes however
the actual ratcliffe was killed by
powoton indians of course pocahontas is
a film more interested in using the
details of america's settlement as a
springboard for its own story
rather than adhering to the specific
factual details of the era
and although it's nice to see a little
dash of reality in a story like this
it's probably best not to go looking to
disney movies for historical accuracy
one of the most striking segments in the
1940 film fantasia
is entitled night on bald mountain set
to the piece of music of the same name
the short depicts a gigantic monstrous
being awakening an assortment of spirits
eventually the spirits and the beasts
are held at bay at the sound of the
peeling bells
and a chorus of monks singing ave maria
though never given a name in fantasia
itself the beast at the center of night
on bald mountain is named
chernabog adult viewers well-versed in
ancient mythology will recognize
chernabog's name
as one derived from the world of slavic
myths
specifically chernabog's name means
black god
and he's also known as the lord of evil
a creature whose deeds were too wicked
to be told in classic mythology
interestingly another ancient being also
seems to have played a part in inspiring
chernabog
in fantasia the host deems taylor refers
to chernabog
as satan bald mountain according to
tradition
is the gathering place of satan and his
followers
though the character is officially named
chernabog design similarities between
fantasia's chanabog and the traditional
depiction of satan are apparent
particularly in their horned heads and
while
night on bald mountain turned out to be
a distinctive enough
endeavor to ensure that chernabog could
stand on its own two demonic feet
grown-up viewers should be able to
appreciate the terrifying nature of
chernabog's true
origins some disney villains
yearn for world domination some want
revenge
others are motivated by prophecies
dictated by magic mirrors
cruella deville however is one disney
villain who keeps her aims
much simpler all she wants is to take
99 dalmatian puppies and turn them into
a fur
coat and sure the scheme concocted by
101 dalmatians puppy fixated antagonists
aren't exactly ripped from reality but
the disney version of author dodie
smith's legendary villain did take cues
from
reality through real life actress
tallulah bankhead
in a 1985 piece for the los angeles
times
animator mark davis revealed that
tallulah bankhead
an actress known for playing
intimidating women was one of the key
inspirations for designing cruella
deville
bankhead's influence didn't stop there
though in the same los
angeles times piece cruella's voice
actor betty lou gerson
reflected that in the first recording
session they told me to see what i could
come up with
the first voice i tried sounded a bit
like tallulah bankhead
everybody said that's it don't change it
clearly disney's iconic take on the
character of cruella deville
owes a massive tip of the hat to
bankhead and it's nice to know that the
inimitable movie star
is still terrifying kids to this day
even if they have no idea who she is
the 2008 pixar classic wall-e
wears its homages to classic cinema on
its sleeve
and one of wally's more explicit
references to the movies can be found in
the principal villain
one who film fans will be sure to
recognize
auto may be designed to look like a
steering wheel but the robot's gigantic
glowing red circle makes it perfectly
apparent that it's supposed to evoke hal
9000
the villainous computer from 2001 a
space odyssey
the two carry similar designs as well as
a shared determination to enact their
own agendas over the well-being of their
human superiors
otto's connection to 2001 becomes even
more explicit in the climactic showdown
between the captain
and auto which employs the richard
strauss composition
also sprach zarathustra that strauss
piece of course
was also used to immensely memorable
effect in 2001 a space odyssey
otto does however depart from hal in one
aspect
hal was voiced by douglas rayne and was
meant to carry a more human quality than
even the movie's flesh and blood
characters
open the pod bay doors hal
i'm sorry dave i'm afraid i can't do
that
conversely auto is voiced by macintok
apple's text to voice software
this gives auto the most lifeless voice
out of all of wally's cast
giving auto unique qualities compared to
hal ensures that this wall-e villain can
work as a stand-alone entity for younger
viewers
and in the process make the character
more than just a meaningless parody of
2001
the alien antagonists in 2005's chicken
little are
fluffy teardrop shaped critters who look
pretty much tailor made to be sold at
your local disney store
however these aliens don't reveal their
true forms until chicken little's final
moments
up until that point these otherworldly
visitors lurk inside
large robots that move around on long
mechanical legs
older viewers of course will take one
look at these machines
and realize they have more than a
passing resemblance to the antagonists
of
h.g wells the war of the worlds
in wells seminal work the alien invaders
move around in giant machines known as
tripods
in the book wells describes the tripods
as
higher than many houses striding over
the young pine trees
a walking engine of glittering metal
striding now across the heather
articulate ropes of steel dangling from
it
the same description pretty much matches
chicken little's own mechanical aliens
this homage proved timely for chicken
little too given that steven spielberg's
war of the worlds also debuted in 2005
placing the tripods firmly back in the
public consciousness
the lion king's villain scar doesn't
exactly hide the fact that he's evil
his contempt for simba is palpable in
their earliest conversations
and he relishes the chance to throw his
own brother
mufasa off a ledge to his death
but in case anyone in the audience
doesn't quite understand the full extent
of scar's cruelty
the lion king offers up a few visual
cues to cement his nefarious nature
during scar's big be prepared musical
number
the animators of the lion king made sure
to bask scar in visual parallels to
contemporary nazi propaganda
nazi imagery is rife throughout the
entirety of be prepared
including scar's hyena henchmen marching
in a goose step formation
while scar looms above them an
arrangement echoing how adolf hitler
would appear at military parades and
rallies
the beams of light surrounding scar
during be prepared
also evoke the lighting devices used at
nazi rallies
thus creating a very creepy image of a
feline fury
the idea to tie scar into nazi imagery
came about incidentally
through an animator doodling scar as
hitler this throwaway picture
inspired the visual team behind the lion
king to create
nazi-related visual parallels all
throughout the be prepared sequence the
result was a sequence that easily
reaffirmed the character's evil nature
while also creating some of the movie's
most striking imagery
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one